picture the front
kazushi of the forward roll in
EO okay I'm going to grab go him into
it it's a kind your T I don't want to I
don't want to kneel here and I want to
get outside
any counter you might have so I'm going
this and then
around
[Music]
here okay s here we go so we'll add a
push and when you feel him brace that's
when you go to the
technique he doesn't necessarily have to
push back although that would be better
but he just braces you see oh he
braces I'm not FY
good
and I'm not looking for anything but
connection at the bottom so pushy
braces I don't want to see chest to back
I don't care about your arms right
now get him to
[Music]
brace okay let's
go so again just to to understand and
the
push
right so I push he pushes I take him
into the
turn I push he pushes I take him into a
turn then I find that s tou push
turn and
on
pushy
pushes so I'm kicking that leg
out I push he
pushes that's f
I push you
pushes okay let's
try Okay so we're in a
clinch and I I'll take this
one okay so same thing I drive he drives
back Tak it into a spiral
go all the way to M leave his arm on
you so I drive he drives
back but I take it into a spiral
Drive
drive me
drive
let's SL back down let's clean up
do so yeah I have this and then I went
for this
tricep camera where are you you see that
tricep this Hook is what I'm going to
do got it you see
yeah so when I push and then he drives
back first let me show you the hook
there's no no energy driving back no
energy and I'm going to use the
hook there's a lot of Leverage in
it
then he now has a Nur going that way so
he goes he goes that
way even more do you understand yes
sir and
now I'll take his inertia
out but it none of his is
inertia and I'm just going to use my
body weight instead of just my
arm way more inertia
right and
now I add his
momentum
it's even
faster way more energy you understand I
Ser
then when I pull down on this weight is
going to go on that
leg he can't step again on that leg to
regain his Valance
he has to step forward do you understand
yes sir so that's where that leg comes
so if you don't
mind you step on that foot that
represents an energy that stops him to
from stepping forward you see and that's
going to affect his balance his leg down
right you all right yeah okay please
that's
so as I come
in I get his egoic mind to contest you
see that's why we train
in
Enlightenment and I'm going to tapack
that leg so he can't step okay and I'm
going to lay down and I'm going to hook
and I'm going to get off the line I'm
going to get a spiral to add centrifugal
energy to his forward energ
so it really takes no
energy just I just lay down I just stay
connected lay down in okay so let's slow
it back down so you can get those
elements
okay here we
go uh he pushes I push
back I I just hold my Center together
and everything turns at once I don't
tilt okay so he pushes I push
back it's when you
resist here he starts to get you
that but if I lock my Center
boom I just let him move me around I let
him move me how far do I let him Sean as
far as he takes as far as he takes me
okay he pushes boom
push he takes me two
times okay that's what we're trying to
do just keep your Center engaged don't
resist him and you won't be able to
to so I push he
braces I turn he does that technique on
me I push he braces does that technique
on so we'll go slow boom he pushes I'm
trying to do the technique he did that
technique you know on this arm this arm
that was here comes inside and we're
[Music]
R
turn
this
okay let's
[Music]
try